am i l I'm loud I normally like to wait
until like one minute past the stated
start time because then if people are
like just grabbing coffee they'll come
in and they won't be sad that it says
it's 3:00 on the dot and I've already
gone so just hang out here for a couple
of
minutes um but yeah thank you all so
much for being here I hope you're
enjoying Copenhagen developer Festival
so far I definitely have been some of
you may have seen me uh get up on stage
and sing some frozen at lunchtime which
might be the scariest thing I've ever
done oh thank you very
much um yeah so very very uh chuffed to
be up alongside you know some some
really really good singers um and it's
just really cool that we have this event
where all these kind of weird talks and
and and sort of bits of entertainment
can come together uh this evening we've
got line breakers for you so I'll be up
on stage again with my French horn and
that should be really good good fun
we've got some new songs this time so
hopefully uh I'll see some of you there
in the audience it's it's going to be a
really good
time not quite at one minute past yet
let give give a little moment for any
any more people to just trickle in are
we all sufficiently caffeinated so far
you all sort of awake in this Mida
afternoon of the middle day of uh
Festival
all right I'm going to start um hi
everyone thanks so much for being here
my name is Eli and I am here today to
talk to you about authenticating your
users over the web um this is this is
will you work got to turn it on that's
crucial uh this is me this is the most
text you'll see on any slide in this
presentation I'm not going to make you
read walls of text or the S
specification or anything um yeah I
currently work as a developer Advocate
at a small cloud provider in Europe
called Gateway based out of France um I
like learning weird things and then
getting up on stage and and telling
people about weird things and you can
find me online uh unfortunately
no for now for now I'm on X or whatever
he's calling it this week so this talk
is about user authentication I'm going
to take you through what authentication
actually is like kind of philosophically
like what is this problem that we're
trying to solve um and why is it
important going to talk about common
ways that we have found of
authenticating users sort of tried and
tested things some things that are new
and it's still in development and still
sort of uh waiting for widespread
adoption and finally going to end by
talking about what makes an
authentication system good when should
use one or versus another uh what kind
of things does some do well and others
don't do so well things like that
so what is authentication well let's say
you're a web developer and you've built
a web app idea ideally you have at least
one user and you as the person who's
building this web app will probably want
to store some data about that user maybe
you've got payment information that
you'd like to store about them and maybe
there are things that only that user
should be able to do like post under a
given
handle and you want to keep all of that
data somewhere in your database of your
web app you want to have like sort of
sovereignty over that data but ideally
you have more than one user you have
quite a lot of users and if you're
draing one person's sort of their data
and things that only they are allowed to
do you need to make sure that only that
person is able to access their stuff you
don't want all the other people having
access to everyone's stuff and in order
to do that you need some way of defining
who a person is within your
system so bit of user story here we all
know and love the user stories as a web
service provider I want to verify that
given user so a person corresp responds
to an identity uh a a programming uh
idea an
identity um so that they can accurately
so appropriately access data and actions
based on that identity who my program
thinks that person is now identity it
turns out it's really hard to Define
what makes me as a person different from
another person is actually like
philosophically a really hard problem we
could spend hours and hours talking
about what it means to to be different
from another human being and how do we
determine that um but we're programmers
and what we do is we use
abstractions but like any abstraction
these can leak they're only ever
approximate so here are some
abstractions that we use you've got
username and password you've got
Biometrics you've got single sign on
with existing uh accounts that you have
with other um web providers you've got
things like Duo and then you've got
things like one-time passwords and these
are all abstractions that we have for
saying this is who a person is they have
access to some knowledge or their
fingerprint or an object like a a one
like like your phone for example and
when you're building a web app this can
all get a little bit overwhelming how do
you know which one to choose do you have
to understand how all of them work in
depth to make an well-informed
decision well if you decide that you do
this talk is essentially a jumping off
point for understanding how on a high
level a lot of these things work and
going a little bit further in depth into
a couple of them that I personally find
really interesting
so let's start with a well-known example
the username and password how this works
is as follows you've got your user
you've got the front end of a web app
that they interact with and that web app
is backed by a server somewhere and this
has your database and it has your
business logic and all of this stuff so
the user goes to the web app and they
want to log in and they put in their
username and password that is then sent
onto the server the server server is
able to verify that that information is
correct corresponds to a user and that
that user should then be allowed to log
in to their account and that's what
happens now here the abstraction we're
using the proxy for identity we're using
is knowledge of a secret knowledge of a
password like knowledge that lives in
your head crucially that you have to
remember as a human
being so it's really important that when
we use knowledge as a proxy for identity
that we keep track of who actually has
ACC access to that knowledge obviously
the user has to that's the whole point
it needs to pass through the front end
but whether or not we consider that to
be equivalent to the front end knowing
it is that a potential point of that
knowledge leaking out into the world
depends on your implementation right and
then there's the server so the server is
pretty interesting um as a thing when
you when you think about passwords and
what I'm about to say is probably well
known to a lot of you but it's worth
going through to really investigate what
we're doing and why we do it when we
store passwords so the server has a
couple of responsibilities it needs to
be able to verify that the user's
password is correct and it needs to
protect that password from leaking out
into the outside world because that
knowledge is axy for identity and if we
let that knowledge leak out then anybody
can claim access to that identity and
that's bad so a naive approach might
just be to store them as records in a
data uh a database now this is bad
obviously because your database is is um
something body gets access to it and
they have all of these records so we
don't do this what we do instead is we
um we obate things and we use hash
functions which are one-way functions
where given the same input you'll always
get the same output but you can't
reverse them so looking at the hash of a
password does not let me recover the
original password you'd have to do
things like looking up a list of values
um and matching them back to what the
original values were so let's say I
happen to know what the hash of the the
password password is I could look and
recognize that but that's not the same
as actually reversing the function
itself so we can do this um we can use
hash functions there's there's quite a
few of them that people use and what we
can do instead is we can simply store
the username and that hash password and
this is good this is this this is a good
first step it means that if your
database is leaked that password has not
been leaked but if you use common
passwords um people might be able to
reverse engineer you sort of by looking
at
common hash functions with common
passwords and go I recognize that one
they've got password one two three and
it's been hashed with this
function another thing that uh makes
this vulnerable is that if your entire
database is dropped and you've used the
same hash function for all of your
passwords that's an extra sort of point
of commonality that an attacker could
use to reverse engineer passwords so we
don't do that either what we do instead
is we add a little bit of data at the
end or at the beginning of passwords
doesn't really matter and we hash that
whole string concatenated together and
what we do is this is called ass salted
hash and that little bit in pink is
called ass salt and we can store that as
part of the database record so when we
get the password in the server goes okay
I need to add that little bit that's
before the dollar sign to the end of the
password then hash it and it should
match the bit that's after the dollar
sign and that way without storing the
password and with also um we also make
essentially we're modifying the hash
function and that hash function can then
be is effectively different for every
single user in your database because you
don't use 7 AF every time you use random
bits random bits of data um and this is
this is good this gives you a lot of
security against sort of brute forcing
attacks because now it takes a lot
longer for a given attacker to go
through your dropped database the
database that's been leaked out and to
discover reverse engineer passwords from
them however if somebody really really
wants to get into your account and they
get hold of your saled hash then they
can still brute force it and they can
still sort of essentially reverse
engineer what your password was for most
passwords that are easily memorable by
people what you end up with if you want
a secure password is things that look
like this to start with that's one of
the hash values from earlier in the
slides and that's really hard to
remember for an actual user like this is
pretty secure this is a secure password
um especially if it's being stored as
assaulted hash but it's hard for a user
to remember and at the end of the day
the user has to be able to authenticate
when we think about the user we can
think about a couple of things users we
can forget our passwords you know how
many times have I gone oh which one was
it I need to log into my rivalry account
or whatever and you'd go through like
three of the ones that I've used in
various places which is awful awful
infos I know but um we can forget our
passwords we can be tricked into giving
away our passwords this is fishing or it
can be done via social engineering
including fishing so when you have a
website that looks very much like the
Target website and somebody puts in
their password thinking it's the real
thing and now now that knowledge is
leaked out into the world and the
attacker has access to the identity on
the real
website um and we can be tempted to
reuse a given strong password I mean I
do this it's not good but it's the
Temptation is real right this is a human
problem that we have is that it's really
hard to remember big long strings of
numbers so how can we do better well one
way that we've come up with of doing
better is multiactor authentication or
as I like to put it my one nod to the
title of this talk you shall not
password which is essentially using more
pieces of more proxies at the same time
to mitigate the risk of a single
abstraction like knowledge of a password
failing we can use multiple abstractions
at once and we require them all to
succeed at the same
time so we commonly divide up
authentication factors into three
categories you've got things you know
like a password things that live in your
head things you have physical objects
that you have access to like a phone or
a hardware token and then things that
you are so Biometrics essentially uh and
th that last category is pretty
interesting because you can't actually
transmit that over the web I can't you
know I don't it's really hard to sort of
transmit like my Google account let's
say isn't locked with my actual
fingerprint it's locked with a hardware
signature from the fingerprint sensor
we'll get into that later um but
essentially these are three ways three
three categories of proxy for identity
that we use and when you're doing
multiactor authentication you could
require two things that the user knows
but if an attacker is able to steal one
thing out of somebody's head through
fishing social engineering whatever um
they might be able to use the exact same
methodology to do the same a second time
with a different piece of knowledge so
it's always better to mix and match and
have something you know and something
you have something you have and
something you are so on so forth so it's
better to do the latter because then you
um mitigate the risk of a single
strategy of attack succeeding multiple
times so what are some options for
multiactor
authentication the first one is my
favorite um Hardware authentication
tokens and these look like this ubik Kei
for example um most smartphones I would
say all smartphones and quite a lot of
laptops now also have them built in so
if it's a roaming if it's a USB key it's
what's called a roaming authenticator
and if it's built into a larger device
it's called a platform Authenticator
and there are some subtle differences
between them but in Broad terms they're
essentially function the same um we'll
get into uh platform authenticators a
bit more later on in the
talk so the way that uh these things
work to prove identity is public key
cryptography and you have a private key
that you don't share with anyone and a
corresponding public key that you do
share with the world and if I want to
verify that I know the private key I can
use it to cryptographically sign some
message send that with uh with you know
my hardware token and send that to
anybody who has knowledge of my public
key and they can use that public key to
verify that the thing I sent to them was
actually signed with that private key um
and then they they know that I have the
private key essentially you can prove
ownership of a secret without giving
away that secret and this is very
powerful it allows you to have an
identity that's essentially the private
key or it's the key pair um and to be
able to asymmetrically uh prove who you
are and what a hardware token is is
essentially that private key baked in at
a hardware level to a physical object
that you own so now we're talking about
a secret that doesn't live in your head
you can't forget it it's actually a
piece of hardware and the way that it
works in practice is you go to your web
app and you say I'd like to log in so
you hit the login button and the front
end goes to the server and says hey this
person wants to log in and we've got on
record that they have a hardware token
associated with this account can you
send me uh a authentication challenge
which is a message that has various
pieces of data in it send that to me and
I will prompt the user to present their
Hardware device whether that's over
Bluetooth by plugging it in NFC there's
a couple different ways you can do this
and the web app goes cool um where's
your hardware token prove to me that you
have this hardware token and the user
does that they present it and then that
authentication challenge that's come all
the way from the server goes onto that
device and is processed in the hardware
of that device is cryptographically
signed sent back well the user has to do
a gesture to prompt the hardware key to
do its thing like you have to use a
fingerprint or press a button or use
face ID and then the authentication
challenge is signed sent back to the
client passed all the way back to the
server which uses its knowledge of your
public key to verify that cryptographic
signing goes cool they have the hardware
token let them in says the web app let
them in or the front end rather and then
you're in hacker voice I'm in and this
is how the flow works when you have a
hardware token and it's just it's just
public key rography and there's a lot of
really interesting stuff in the spec
about how this actually works and the
mechanics of preventing the hardware
token from leaking the private key out
into a computer that it's plugged into
so some advantages of this are that the
device uh knows about the web service
that authentication Challenge from the
server contains data about the web
service you're logging into so
goggle.com can't steal your secrets
fishing just doesn't work anymore
because it the hardware token can verify
that the request is coming from a
legitimate web service that it knows
about the private key never leaves that
device all that processing is done on
the device itself some really really
cool like Hardware stuff going on in
there really cool um crypto circuits I
forget the terminology but it's really
really interesting so your
authentication come challenge comes into
the token it is signed on device and the
signed response is sent back none of
that happens on the device the computer
that you're using to log in right the
device requires the user to be present
to press a button to use fingerprints so
hit the button you know fingerprint on
your phone and what this means is that
if you leave a device plugged in to a
computer a UB key a the private key
never leaves the device so it can't be
got out through malware and B if you
have some malware on your computer
that's like spamming the token with
loads of requests in order to try and
reverse engineer the private key it
won't work unless you're there pressing
the button to make it do the thing every
time so this is a pretty strong
protection against vulnerabilities in
the hardware that your token interfaces
with downsides though they're expensive
they're not accessible to a lot of
people lots of people don't want to have
to buy a a USB that they can lose really
easily I mean you can you can lose them
very easily I would know um and well
yeah that's the other yeah you can lose
them so they're not actually very usable
a lot of the time I want to log into my
work Google account but I left my USB at
home and now it's I left my UB ke at
home and now it's a whole thing you know
um so this is some drawbacks within
minut that's why we haven't seen sort of
widespread mainstream adoption of these
you see them mostly among software
developers uh but we do have them built
into a lot of our smartphones now and
this is mainstream uh and and widespread
adoption of Hardware tokens um so
whenever you have your banking app and
you need to verify a transaction and you
use your fingerprint that's actually um
that's the verification gesture for the
hardware token that's built into your
phone so that's what's happening there
and these are getting more and more use
uh with pass Keys which I will talk
about later in this talk so we've got
onetime passwords I'm going to speed up
a little bit because I'm realized that
I'm going slower than I intended so
onetime passwords the way that these
work you'll you'll probably has anyone
in this room not used these before yeah
right we we all know what these are
you've got a phone a code on your phone
and or in your email whatever
so you go to log into your web app and
you say I'd like to log in please the
web app goes to the server and says
please generate for me a code you can
also do this in a Time based way that's
how Google Authenticator works is it
does um it factors in the current time
to generate codes that's where they
change every 60 seconds or 30 seconds um
the server says here's a code let me
send it to the phone number that I have
on file and the user can look at that
enter it in and be verified and this is
something you have the user has access
to this phone and that's the proxy that
we're using
um however you can clone Sims this is
not hard uh the amount of security that
goes on in um phone numbers across
networks is shockingly low like really
really low if anybody knows about this
you know what I'm talking about like
it's quite scary actually so it's really
really easy to gain access to texts that
somebody else is receiving and that
makes sms-based one-time passwords not
very secure they're better than nothing
but they're not secure um so uh things
like Google authentic Ator are much
better methods for doing this doing this
over email is much better uh you can
also lose your phone I got I had a phone
get run over once dropped it in the
middle of the road and came back like
five minutes later realizing that I'd
lost it was faintly buzzing in the
middle of the road heartbreaking um and
then what do you do you're locked out of
your accounts because you can't use your
phone to authenticate with them anymore
so this is also a
problem magic Link login is very similar
to a one-time code and the way that it
works is you have the slack does this
has again has anyone not seen this
before cool preach into the choir works
exactly like very similarly to onetime
passwords you put in your email it says
send you a link server says cool let me
send a link to an authenticated session
to the email address we have on file for
you goes to your email you click it it
takes you to an authenticated session
and this is really usable because if
you're using the web you have an email
address like this is really accessible
to a lot of people it doesn't require
you to have a smartphone it doesn't
require you to have phone signal it just
requires you to have internet which you
zum you already do because you're trying
to log into an online service uh it also
just by clicking on a link um you can't
like fat finger and type the wrong code
you know I'm typing on my phone the
six-digit code and I get it wrong and
it's frustrating and it's a whole pain
in the ass that doesn't happen here you
are relying on the security of your mail
server when you do this if someone can
intercept at this stage get the link and
access it before you they'll be into
your account so I mean a lot of the time
we rely on things like Gmail there
security budget is bigger than you know
bigger than any web app probably that
you use that's not made by Google for
example so that's not a particularly big
security hole but it is worth
considering if you're I don't know
running your own mail server so that's
how magic Link login works yeah people
have emails um that it's widely
accessible however you can get locked
out of your email when I worked at my
last job at Anvil we had a lot of people
who signed up with student accounts who
then lost access to them because they
graduated and getting back into their
accounts where they email was the
primary identifier was actually quite
technically difficult sometimes so
that's something to be aware of as well
now you've gone through a few methods of
multiactor authentication think about
how much how many online accounts you
have like I don't know Twitter sorry X I
know I'm on masteron like you know eBay
Facebook all the random shops that I've
ever logged into and think about how
much effort it would take to set up a
multiactor uh a second authentication
Factor on all of those different sites
it's a lot of effort people just simply
aren't going to do that that's a lot of
overhead it's a lot of user
friction or in a work context think
about how many accounts you have as part
of your work as a developer you know
slack whatever code management Source
you use your HR tool like maybe figma or
something or you know your whiteboarding
tools or Zoom all of these different
things and if you are a sis admin for
all of those imagine setting up
maintaining and keeping like maintaining
and uh clearing away when an employee
leaves second factors for all of those
things absolute nightmare just an
incredibly complex task to do so we
would like to have something better than
this something more usable than this it
would be really nice if we could just
have one account that we signed into and
then all of our other things kind of
piggybacked off that and that's what
single sign on is it's essentially the
idea that you have service providers
which are the apps that we've been
talking about so things like the the
shop where I go and buy all my yarn or
um I don't know Hacker News or something
and then you also have a web service
provider that what they do for you is
provide an identity so Google for
example youve got Microsoft GitHub does
this Facebook you can do this with
Facebook you used to be able to do it
with Twitter don't know if that's still
true um and the identity provider
handles the authentication on behalf of
the service provider so the way that
this works is you have an identity
provider that this is where your
identity lives it provides a central
place for you to do things like use
strong authentication factors and to
make updates to things like your name um
or your address or your payment details
for example and then lots of other
service providers will rely on that
identity provided by the identity
provider now this is great because yeah
you can centralize things like your
security and updates to your name and
your details and things like this
however um and the way that it works is
like this so you've got your service
provider I've gone to my yarn shop let's
say I want to buy some more wool
and I've said I want to log in so that I
can look at all of the the things that
I've got on my wish list and in my
shopping basket and the service provider
says cool I notied that you log in with
Google let me send you to Google that's
your identity provider and you'll have
to authenticate there with whatever
method you have chosen for your Google
account so you do that and you're
authenticated with your identity
provider your identity provider then
redirects you back to the service
provider along with some kind of token
of proof of your identity and what the
token actually is depends on the the me
mechanisms used for this but something
some piece of data that the service
provider can look at can pause and use
to verify that you are who you said you
were and then you're logged in and
that's it it's just delegating um
authentication to a third
party that's that's what SSO is it's
really that simple where it gets tricky
is the implementations so we'll talk
about that in a
moment uh it's great because web
services now don't need to store your
credentials all that Guff about um
storing passwords and salted hashes just
don't do that just hand it over to
Google users don't need to remember lots
of passwords you have one account you
have maybe one long big big long
password and you can use your hardware
token in one place and gain the benefits
across multiple
places however if you lose that identity
let's say Google is compromised suddenly
all of those identities that were're
relying on it are also compromised so
you're putting all your eggs in one
basket somewhat however you know a lot
of these big identity providers they're
baskets with big security budgets so
that's a reason able
tradeoff so this is the fun stuff how we
can actually Implement SSO there are two
main methods that I'm going to talk
about um there's saml which stands for
security assertion markup language and
open ID
connect right saml I love this section
who here has worked with SEL
before my
condolences I love this I spent days and
days reading the S specs and just
turning my head inside out being like
how does this how is this working so
Samuel follows the method the sort of
broad overview that I just talked about
where you get redirected back and forth
in order to authenticate and when you
log in when you want to log in to a saml
service provider let's say your HR
System at work you go I'd like to log in
and then you are redirected to the
identity provider for that saml identity
and you're redirected in your
browser um and what you are sent what's
sent along with you from the service
provider is a thing called an
authentication request and this contains
data about
what the services you're trying to log
into who you're trying to log in as um
what or um what maybe method that you've
tried to log in with like let's say you
try to use a password or something um
sorry that's uh what um sorry that's not
correct uh just who you are and what
you're trying to look into and then what
happens is that is um cryptographically
signed by a certificate on the part of
the service provider the service
provider said as proof of who I am this
web app I'm going to sign this request
with my um public key uh with my with my
with my um certificate my my like SSL
certificate for
example and that and the identity
provider has knowledge of that public
key can decrypt that and pause it and
say okay this person's try and log into
the HR System and I am going to make
them authenticate here with me the
identity provider so you do that and
then the uh user is redirected back in
their browser back to the service
provider along with a s authentication
assertion and this is where you have
data about what the person is allowed to
do and the methods that was used to log
in so let's say that you use the
hardware token at the identity provider
that might be part of the S um assertion
and that is also cryptographically
signed by a certificate belonging to the
identity provider and the s service
provider has knowledge of that public
key associated with it is able to
decrypt it use it verify it log the user
in now I've specifically called out
cryptographic signing here as a thing
that is very is necessary because you
have to have the service provider and
the identity provider able to trust each
other's
identities um oh oh what's going on oh
yeah user is logged in I had one more
slide that I forgot about one really
interesting thing about this is um it's
all happening via user browser redirects
the two entities don't talk directly to
each other it's all browser redirects
with attached XML data essentially and
that means that your identity provider
doesn't have to be on the public web it
can be behind it can be in an air gap
Network um I suppose not air but it can
be in a network that's running on behind
in your own company infrastructure uh
and you can use that to log into web
accounts on the public web as long as
you're on the network that has access to
the identity provider that's pretty cool
that's I don't know how useful that is
ever really but it's neat that you can
do
it um the reason I brought out
cryptographic signing is because signing
XML data is really really really hard
and I'll will show you why here are two
bits of saml code data
they mean the same thing but if you
write a cryptographic signature if you
generate a cryptographic signature over
the two of them you'll get two different
things because cryptographic signing
hyps over bite strings not over semantic
data semantically they're the same but
as strings they're different and they're
both valid saml even though obviously
we' really prefer the first one right so
they both mean the Sul issuer is
whatever's in between those
brackets so when we have two bits of
saml that mean the same thing but are
written differently we'd really like to
extract that semantic data and sort of
um have the signing work over the shared
meaning that they have so that we can
have the same signature generated for
two things that mean the same thing we'd
like some process that extracts that
semantic data and that process is called
canonicalization you can put SLE data
into canonical
forms but the issue with this so then
you put you you canonicalize all your
data and then you generate a sign a
signature over it and that means that
you can actually understand that the
signatures refer to the same data that
you were
sent however your service provider and
your identity provider have to agree on
the canonicalization algorithm that
you're using to do this and there's not
just one there's a bunch of them and
there isn't a industry standard they're
also really really hard to do and this
is Complicated by the fact that there is
no formal structure for samal
authentication assertions and uh
requests you can have multiple
authentication requests within the same
samle message it's an absolute like
trash fire over there it's great um so
sble is really really complicated to get
right but if you do get it right it's
pretty secure and it's pretty usable
it's you know click a button go to the
place you sign in sign in and now you're
in so the other way that we do SSO and
this is what you'll all have probably
used in your everyday life um is open ID
connect and this again follows a very
similar path um with some differences
and if You' ever seen a dialogue that
looks like this you've used it this is
what this is open ID
connect so oidc uses Json web tokens
rather than XML for um trans sort of
tokens of proof of who you are and
requests and so on so forth and the
difference here is that Json web tokens
do have canonical forms that are golden
paths for encrypting them canonicalizing
them and passing them tokens are passed
by the service provider so when you log
back when you when you are sent back to
your service provider along with a token
of yes this user logged in um um the
service provider can understand that and
say yeah cool I understand who this user
is but they can also reach back out to
the identity provider to verify them so
there's an extra layer of security there
in that they can reach out to contact
the service the identity provider
directly and verify uh that tokens are
actually valid this means that your oidc
server cannot be within a it has to be
on the public web or has to be
accessible directly for the two entities
to talk to each other unlike saml the
way that this works is is um you have
your user go to your service provider
and you say I would like to log
into I don't know session eyes I'm a
speaker I use session eyes and I log in
with Google so I say I'd like to log in
and then session eyes sends me to Google
and it sends me to the authorization
endpoint of Google's oidc server and
here is where I log in I I verify my
identity with um you know uh my
fingerprint Etc so
on and then what I'm done with what
happens is the server sends me back to
the uh service provider with an
authorization code and this is just like
a string and that authorization code
corresponds to a record in the database
in the oidc server and from this point
onwards my job as the user is done all
the communication happens between the
two entities so the service provider
sends that or code back to the server to
a token endpoint it says I've got this
authorization code can you give me a
token and the server goes and looks up
that authorization code in its database
and says sure I can I can verify that
this is a legitimate thing that you're
asking for let me give you a token
representing that login event of that
user and that token is called an ID
token it's it's not really a token in
the same way that beer token a tokens
it's more a record of an author
authentication event that gets sent back
to the service provider the service
provider can pause it and say yeah Eli
logged in with Google and this is their
account and this is the account that I
have associated with them so they can
log in to their session eyes and submit
a speaker submit a talk for NDC London
right and at that point the web service
could let me just log in it doesn't have
to do anything further but if it wants
to it can take that ID token and it can
send it to an introspection endpoint on
that server for extra um security that
it is really a valid token like maybe
they want to check if it's expired and
that introspection endpoint can give the
service provider more data about the
user who logged in the user who is
referred to in that authentication event
that the token
represents um and the server can send
back yeah this token is still valid or
no this token isn't valid anymore and at
that point the service provider can be
really really confident that you are who
you say you are according to a trusted
identity
provider any questions that was I feel
like that's the most complicated setup
that's the most complicated flow that we
have in this talk
question
sorry
can oh okay so a service can use this so
that's why uh the question is is it
possible for applications to use this
and not just users that's what oo is and
oidc is built on top of ooth so ooth is
built for applications to have access to
like resources maybe do you want to let
Dropbox access your photos in Google
Drive or whatever um and that is uh
that's the mechanism that oadc has built
on top of it's like a layer you can use
a directly for authentication but it's
full of foot guns it's really easy to do
it wrong and leave gaps in security so
that's why oadc was created as a
basically syntactic sugar on top of oor
um to make this particular use case much
easier and more seamless so yes um
that's also a different talk which I
would love to I would love to write but
um I'm happy to talk about it with you
afterwards aor is really really cool um
and kind of hard to understand I found
it very hard to understand when I got
into it cool so that's
oidc and in this method uh the two
entities communicate directly this means
that you they both have to be able to
actually talk to each other they have to
be able to do that but it also gives you
an extra layer of security against spoof
tokens because the service provider can
always go I have this token let me go
and check with the person who supposedly
issued it to me the identity provider
that's that it's
legit you can also extend this there's a
user info endpoint let's say I've got
I'm a service provider I've got a token
and I'd like to know this user's email I
can actually go and ask and see if I'm
allowed to know that about the user at
this end point so that's particularly
useful for like oh would you like to let
this web app access your payment details
that you have stored in Google for
example so it's really nice for
providing sort of a good user experience
and better
security right past keys I'm glad I've
left myself enough time to really talk
about these because these are really
cool so past keys are quite new they
don't have widespread adoption yet but
they are mature enough that I no longer
can leave them out of this talk and
they're very very cool so here's this
logo if you see this logo is pass Keys
um it's like everywhere you talk about
pass Keys you must use this logo and I
really hope they don't come after me for
like editing it into the colors of these
slides but here we are um pass keys are
an initiative that's currently being run
by Google Microsoft and Apple so some
big identity providers and what they are
are allowing you to use Hardware
authentication tokens built into your
phone or with you know laptop without
loss of generality platform
authenticators that are registered to
your Google account your Microsoft
account so on so I've got an Android
phone the platform authenticator on that
phone is registered to my Google account
Google knows that that authenticator
belongs to me and essentially using
those to daisy chain security to a bunch
of key pairs that are stored in the
cloud so every time you want to to
create a new account somewhere you go
I'd like to create a new key pair that
lives in my Google Cloud again without
lot of generality and which will be
encrypted with the password to my Google
account so we haven't quite got away
from passwords entirely but we might
move towards a model where passwords
essentially become encryption keys for
lots of key pairs that live in your
cloud account um and then when you want
to log in somewhere you log in with your
phone and you can um you can log in with
your phone or your laptop there's
various different flows for using the
hardware platform authenticator on the
device that you have that's tied to your
account to unlock decrypt and use the
individual key pairs that are associated
with the specific service providers does
that makes sense it's quite circuitous
or it can
be okay no raised hands um so this is
how that flow looks um I've I've kind of
got rid of the user here essentially but
I as a user I go to my web app and I say
I'd like like to log in again to session
eyes let's say let's say that I'm using
that I'm using this instead of oidc FR
um and I have previously um logged into
sessional ised and said I want to
generate a key pair a pass key um that
lives in my Google Cloud account that is
related to this account and that I can
use to authenticate and so what happens
when I go to login let's say from a new
device I go the um session eyes the web
app goes to it knows that I have a pass
key that's used in the authentication
method so it goes to Google this this
Pass key logo in the middle represents
the service the identity provider and
the store of key pairs that it has in
the cloud encrypted with my password it
goes to Google and it says Eli wants to
log in here can I use the key pair that
you have on file for them to
authenticate in the same flow that you
do with like um Hardware
tokens it's like a virtual hardware
token in the cloud and the way that that
virtual hardware token is unlocked and
ready to be used is that Google then
goes to my phone and says you want you
said you wanted to log into to session
eyes before I can unlock and use the
pass key that you have stored for it you
need to authenticate on your device with
your fingerprint with your face ID by
making that gesture to make your
hardware token um to authenticate with
your hardware token that's on your phone
and when you do that you do the gesture
that says yes I'm here and I want to
unlock these pass keys that
consent that is cryptographically like
secured consent because again it's this
is an authentication challenge that's
being signed by your hardware token in
the same way that it was with like a the
UB example we saw that signed challenge
is sent back to Google and Google goes
cool I can verify that the user said yes
they um authenticated on their device
that I know belongs to them I can be
cryptographically very confident in this
because it's using a hardware token and
now I know that I'm allowed to decrypt
the pass key I have stored in the cloud
and use that to log in to session I and
that's how that works and it took me the
longest time and now you're logged in
took me the longest time to understand
how you could have a pass key a pass a
hardware token that was on your phone
that was somehow you being used across
lots of like through the cloud while
that private key wasn't ever leaving the
device and it's because the pass keys
that you're logging using to log into to
your service providers are not the same
ones as the one that lives on your
platform device that's simply used as a
as a check it's it's daisy chaining um
key pass essentially um so that's how
that works and paries have a few
different qualities that are interesting
to talk about it protects against device
loss because what you can do is you can
register multiple Hardware tokens to
your Google Cloud account so I could
register another UB key to my Google
Cloud account and use that instead of my
phone to be able to unlock the store of
pass keys that lives in the cloud
suddenly all of these Hardware these
sort of virtual Hardware tokens that
live in the cloud because they're
virtual I can't lose them it's they're
they're backed by all of the security of
of Google's Cloud essentially and again
without loss of generality your your
identity provider of choice
um you know if I lose my phone suddenly
I haven't lost access to all those
accounts as long as I have a way to get
into my account and register a hardware
authenticator I can keep using those
pass keys that already exist I don't
have to change
them it also uses user verification as
opposed to user presence so user
presence is if I have to press a button
somebody's there but use of verification
is when you use
Biometrics somebody's there and it's
specifically this person so that's when
you get the interesting thing of you're
using Biometrics not just as a gesture
of sort of like somebody is here and is
saying yes you can do this but the
person I care about is here and saying
yes you can do this um and these are
terms that you'll see in sort of
security world if you're interested in
stuff like user verification and user
presence and user sort of various
different things like this um and it's
better to have verification it's better
to have verification than presence just
because somebody's there pressing a
button doesn't mean it's the person that
you actually care care about but if you
have Biometrics that's what you
get this uh technology is currently
dependent on big identity providers so
unlike um
open-source uh password managers for
example we don't currently I believe
have open source Pass Key storage
generation I think it's coming there are
I think bit Warden is working on it
there's a few um I haven't looked in a
month or so to see if there's been
updates in that Arena but that is going
to happen you are not going to
eventually be dependent on big corporate
clouds and identity providers for using
this technology and what that will also
get you is crossplatform pass keys
because at moment if I want to use apple
pass keys I can't use them on an Android
phone because that platform of
authenticator is not tied into my Apple
account um so at the moment
crossplatform pass keys are hard to do
if you're using if your bought into one
ecosystem but you want to use a device
that's not a part of that ecosystem for
example but that is changing that's
coming very soon and it's going to be
very exciting and in general it's always
really good when security stuff happens
sort of out in the open like you've got
open source versions because it means
that very very smart people can look at
it and verify that it's going that it's
good right you know it's there's a
reason that
like um private crypto uh not um
cryptography isn't like a thing it's
because like we it's good to have it
done out in the open so that all like
the experts can come and look at it and
go yeah that's secure actually that's
that's good enough um so that's really
cool I really like P keys I think
they're they're technically interesting
and they have a lot of good usability
features so final section we have 15 odd
minutes left um and we we won't we won't
go to fulltime this is about like 5 10
minutes what makes an authentication
system good we've talked about lots of
different ways to authenticate people
various security postures of them and
how they work but at the end of the day
it doesn't really matter unless you've
got users that use your thing and it
works for them so obviously we need
security if your authentication system
isn't secure you might as well not have
one right and this is why I'd like to
come back to the humble username and
password if you've got username or
passwords that look like this that's
actually quite secure but the thing is
that to use them securely you have to
know loads and loads and loads and loads
of them and this is hard and passw
managers help um but they only go so far
and they also introduce big points of
single points of failure so we've had
last pass got Pops like it happens again
and again every couple of years um but
if implemented correctly and if the user
remembers 50 passwords that look like
hashed values to begin with it's secure
but that's not usable right you end up
with people writing things down reusing
passwords so on so forth if something is
hard to use securely it's insecure
because people will end up bypassing the
ways in which it is secure so you have
to consider not only security but
usability and um which one is this oh
yeah um you can't trust users to make
good decisions and uh I once knew a
brilliant brilliant engineer and he
pasted his master password into
slack it it happens to the best of us
you cannot rely on users behaving
perfectly if your users have to behave
perfectly for your system to work then
it's a bad system so we need both
security and ease of use when we're
designing an authentication system and
I'd like to come back here to saml if
implemented correctly this is both
secure and easy for the end
user but it's incredibly hard to
implement
correctly there I would put it to you
that there is not a single secure really
secure saml uh implementation out
there if something is hard to implement
securely for us as developers then it's
also going to be
insecure so actually there's a third
pillar here that sometimes I think
doesn't get brought up in these
conversations and it's ease of
implementation if something's hard for
us to build right we're going to build
it wrong and that's not good enough so
we need to have things that are easy to
use easy to build and secure by
Design and for that reason I like pass
keys if I'm able to stand up here and
kind of explain in Broad terms how they
work
that's good that's that's a good uh sign
that conceptually they're easy enough
for to understand how they work and to
work with them as developers there are
golden paths being developed for their
use you we've got very good uh like very
good engineers at lots of these big
places these big uh Cloud identity
providers and also on the open source
side working to make these things easy
to use Easy to implement and secure so I
don't I don't normally at the end of
this talk this is the first time I've
thrown in like a conclusion of like
actually I really like this particular
thing normally I've gone oh it's up to
you look at your constraints
everything's going to be different for
different people I really like par keys
I think they're really interesting I
really encourage people to go away read
about them um see if you can get them
set up with some of your accounts uh
Phil Nash who is another speaker at NDC
he's not here right now but he has a
really great talk about them as well
which you can go away and look up um it
was by watching his talk that I
understood how they worked like I had
the light bulb moment so I really
thought go uh encourage you to go and
look that up for discussion of how they
can be uh much how how the user
experience of pass keys can be improved
and streamlined and and and you know um
where the development is going with that
um so that wraps me up what have we
learned we've talked about what
authentication actually is you the idea
of extracting identity and using proxies
and why we need it so other people don't
get hold of your stuff and post as you
on X or whatever we talked about how we
do it lots and lots of different methods
for doing it and uh how we can choose
between them and why it's difficult and
finally we've talked about how to do
authentication well the things you have
to consider you know security ease of
use and even implementation and
usability mattering not only for the
users but for us as developers
developing these systems thank you very
much any
[Applause]
questions any
questions
hang on I'm going to come down just so I
can definitely hear you oh fantastic
hello uh is a usual developer uh I want
to provide for example this uh what's
the word session know the keys you
recommend pass Keys uh so if we need to
support both
Android uh lovers and iPhone lovers do
we need to for than both
buttons uh login with Google log in with
apple good question I would so the
question is um actually no you had a mic
so I don't need to repeat a question
fantastic um I don't know I would hope
that well yeah it depends because if
you've got par key stored in two
different clouds you're going to have to
decide which one you want to use it's
not going to be as simple as living in
the same cloud and this par key was
generated by Apple and that par key was
generated by by AA or whatever your
Microsoft account um yeah potentially
you might have multiple pass keys in
multiples accounts um I can see that
being the way that it goes I can also
see that being a point of friction that
people want to reduce over time and and
development effort efforts going towards
sort of homogenizing things in that way
um I think it'll probably end up being
uh a push and pull between because
obviously these big cloud providers
these big CL identity providers they
want their users to stay with them they
want you they want to be sticky to their
users they don't want people becoming
agnostic um they they sort of they do in
the sense that like making users happy
is good and makes them stick around but
they're not necessarily going to make it
easy for you to take all of your pass
Keys away from give a given identity
provider and put them in bit warden for
example because it's not in their
interest to do that like not to get to
like ah capitalism about it but um I see
that being an ongoing source of friction
for users honestly
but it's no worse than a lot of the
things we have now I would say um and
the rest of the benefits of p keys I
think make them still worthwhile do that
does that answer your
question hello uh yeah I wanted to ask
that the basically the P Pass Key
solution that was suggested is making
the hardware key uh to the virtual cloud
like to be managed by these big
corporations and does that make get a
real like does that create a bigger
point of failure that compared to I have
a local password manager when it fails
uh my stuff get hacked but if the big
company they get hacked then everyone
using it with every account it gets
hacked uh everything uh does that or is
that a risk that we are willing to take
we trust them that the the chance is
much lower than my account get hacked
yes so the question about again putting
all your eggs in one basket in this way
um it's no worse than storing your pass
passwords with chrome I think um which I
definitely do like built-in password
managers into your browser are really
good and have opened up the idea of
using a password manager of people and
this is kind of a natural extension of
that um so one thing that I don't I
don't know if it's going to change or if
it's been baked in so early into pass
keys that it's kind of here to stay is
the idea of your pass Keys being
encrypted with the password to your
Google Microsoft Apple account um
because that is one protection against
let's say the entire store of pass keys
for a given region gets leaked is that
they are they have been encrypted with
your password and if that's a strong
password and in theory it should be
because it might be the only one you
actually ever need to use in the future
um then that's decent protection against
those key pairs being taken and used
elsewhere because they are encrypted at
at rest um and they're only decrypted
when you have when um there's an active
sort of you have authenticated with your
platform device and sort of very
specific permissions to unlock that
keeper has been given
um yeah I think it's always a concern
whenever you centralize your
authentication is well what happens if I
lose that that thing that I'm building
all of my you know security
infrastructure on top of is that a is
that a firm foundation
um yeah I trust the security team at
these big well maybe Microsoft lesso
although that's probably heresy to say
at an NDC conference but the security in
a lot of these places I trust more so
than um you know me running my own bit
Warden server somewhere right so sorry
Vault Warden I think is what it is when
it's you on yourself but
um yeah it's a good concern it's it's a
valid concern there isn't really an
answer to it um does that I was say
there isn't an answer does that answer
your question but is does that help is
that was that
useful any more for
anym we can all run and get some coffee
for next sessions
all right I'll let you go thank you so
much for being here I hope you continue
to enjoy the rest of the conference and
um yeah come see us on stage this
evening come and watch the line break
because it's going to be a great
time